director Wes Craven might have dreamed
up Freddy but it took a whole team of
people to bring him to life the physical
process of transforming actor Robert
England into Freddy Krueger with layers
of latex tubes and the occasional goat
bladder took around 3 and 1/2 to 4 hours
going through that lengthy makeup
application process helped England get
into the headp space to inhabit Freddy
and he drew inspiration from classic
movie Monsters Freddy's signature slouch
was born out of necessity but it also
had a less Sinister inspiration actor
James Kagney England told the guardian
the way Freddy always stands with his
legs far apart was something I stole
from James Kagney a pose that signifies
sheer power people wonder why Freddy has
this strange posture with his right
shoulder slouched but it was because
that claw was so heavy it weighed me
down but I like the way it made me look
like a cowboy drawing a gun